durch meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem fahrer und
antwort video heute hier am montag ich
habe mein twitter gefragt ob er
irgendwelche fragen an mich habt und sie
sollte der mich zu bieten und da könnt
ihr mir auch gerne folgen denn ihr bei
solchen sachen dabei sein wollt oder
andere tolle tweets von mir gehört
jedenfalls werde ich das ganze jetzt mal
beantworten
möchtest du in deiner jetzigen situation
etwas ändern wollen eigentlich bin ich
deshalb in meinem leben komplett
zufrieden da reißt sie was ich gerne
hätte wäre mehr freizeit um noch mehr zu
schaffen also ich habe derzeit sonne
tool ist in meinem college block mit
allen möglichen sachen nicht mehr machen
möchte videos die nicht reden möchte
sachen die ich so noch unbedingt machen
möchte wo ich hin reisen möchte was ich
noch erledigen muss und so was alles auf
das schaffe ich derzeit einfach nicht
alles zu erledigen das heißt wenn ich
etwas an meiner situation ändern könnte
wäre es mir mehr freizeit zu beschaffen
was ist deine lieblings pokémon
editionen pokémon feuerrot weil das die
mit der ich angefangen habe pokémon zu
spielen hast du nächster zeit größere
beziehungsweise längere reisen geplant
ich werde vom 14
juni bis zum 19 juni nach new york
fahren ich werde am 20
juni für einen tag nach berlin fahren
ich bin am 13 juni in düsseldorf beim
wort videopreis ich werde bald an die
nordsee noch mal fahren zum urlaub
einfach dann werde ich im september
etwas mit krankhafter machen da werdet
ihr euch denke ich schon sehr darauf
freuen weil ich eine woche mit dem
verreisen werde da ist noch eine menge
geplant allerdings nie längere sachen
als ihnen die meine woche oder zwei
wochen weil einen monat kann ich jetzt
einfach mit rooney und lernen und videos
machen und vor produzieren
das geht nicht so ein herr was es für
dich der sinn des lebens freiheit glaube
ich also das muss natürlich jeder für
sich selbst definiert aber für mich ist
glaube ich freiheit also das zu tun und
lassen kann was du möchtest du nicht
dass du irgendwie unbedingt arbeiten
mussten im job denn überhaupt nicht
gefällt
nur damit du weiterleben kannst und dein
leben finanzieren kannst also einfach
dass man sich freiheit schafft das ist
glaube ich so der sinn des lebens aber
das muss jeder für sich selbst irgendwie
festhalten was du eine apple bosch
gekauft und wenn ja welches modell ja
ich finde apple bosch gekauft das wissen
denke ich alle die mir bei instagram
folgen wenn du hast es wieder scheiße
man man man wenn man ein video auch
immer direkt ist jedem haus herum
schreiben ich habe mir die normale apple
watch gestellt als mich die sport aber
auch nicht diese was weiß ich wie teure
edition also dieses mittel gegen weil
ein besseres glas hat als die normale
sport und ich bin jemand der sich nur
kauf mehr geld in die reparatur
investiert als in die usa
die müsste am 15.6 ankommen da bin ich
zwar grad in new york aber ich hoffe mal
dass man den nachbarn die nicht klar
jedenfalls wenn ich dann auch in videos
zu der apple watch machen und das werdet
ihr auch schon mitbekommen wenn ich die
dann habe aber ja ich habe mir eine
gekauft machst du videos wenn du in
amerika bist ja werde ich allerdings
werden die verzögert hochgeladen werden
tun wollen was ist es für euch glaube
ich gerade spiegelverkehrt aber ich
fliege am 20 das ist ein samstag zurück
das heißt am sonntag bin ich wieder in
deutschland richtig und vom montag vom
22 bis zum 27
wird jeden tag ein new york wieder
kommen natürlich am dienstag und am
freitag wird nur eine folge von den
comments kommen weil das ihrem am
dienstag und am freitag kommt allerdings
wird in der zeit jeden tag new york
wieder kommt da bin ich richtig viele
filme richtig viel arbeit geben beim
schneiden hab ich bock drauf allerdings
habe ich derzeit auch mit snapshot
öffentlich gemacht ich heiße bei switch
and laser luca da könnt ihr mich enden
und da werde ich mir für new york
sondern new york auslands telekom flat
kaufen das heißt da werde ich wenn ich
in new york verdienen wir auf dem empire
state building stehe werde ich dann da
jetzt ins netz setzen und wenn ich durch
die city lauf von alles mögliche das
snap chat seht ihr dann so sachen wie
wenn ich dusche oder auch wenn ich auf
video preis bin wer die sachen filmen
oder halt wenn ich in new york wenn das
heißt da könnt ihr mir wenn ihr wollt
doch gerne folgen also nur wenn ihr da
sehen wollt wenn ihr live sehen wollt
wie ich in new york was erlebe und sonst
weht er soll auch auf youtube die
beschreibst du die arbeit an seinem buch
ich verstehe die frage nicht so ganz
also wenn ich mitbewerb oder mit dem
adjektiv beschreiben müsste wäre es auf
jeden fall cool und ich sammle dadurch
eine menge erfahrungen
ich habe ich gedacht diese arbeit seinem
buch ist das macht keinen spaß
allerdings macht es unglaublich viel
spaß das ist einfach so du erschaffst
quasi was und wenn man immer jeden tag
meines alters zwei seiten vorankommens
megacool dh in der zeit wird sehr krass
am arbeiten und ich denke es wird cool
ich stecke sehr viel zeit rein und ich
hoffe es wird cool aber ich denke es
wird cool dauert ja eh noch bis
rauskommt kommt er im september oder
oktober oder so kannst du malaga punkte
spiel ich wollte das damals mal zocken
allerdings ging das bei mir da nicht und
dann hat doch nicht mehr so viel die
motivation daran dass aufzunehmen
allerdings haben dass ihr jetzt zum
baker dot grand palais und noch viel
mehr deutsche youtuber schon gespielt
deswegen denke ich werde ich das auch
mal ausprobieren und dann sehen wie die
tage mal hochladen wenn ihr darüber
welche farbe hat ein t shirt ach egal
ich frag einfach den clever bord ja ich
denke ich mir das video hier oben und
zwar habe ich aber das ist eine website
die schau dir das video an und er wusste
echt alles was sich irgendwie an hatte
das heißt ihr könnt mir jetzt sagen ja
du hast gerade ein dunkelblaues t-shirt
an oder so und du hast blonde haare und
was weis ich konnte er mir alles
beantworten richtig kraft ich bin da
immer noch voll geflecht von ich habe
bock davon sollen zweiten oder dritten
teil hochzuladen also einfach so ich wie
ich noch mal mit dem plakat hinter
agiere ich weiß wie hat er davon der
reihe gemacht wurde schon bei folge 90
ist oder so was
also das soll gar keine konkurrenz
darstellen ich habe einfach bock auf
dieses ding und schreibt wieder bock
vorab könnt ihr mir mal in die
kommentare schreiben
welcher von zweiten teil oder so machen
wann kommt mal wieder ein böse
kommentare lesen die sache mit dem böse
kommentare lesen ist so ich habe davon
der drei videos hochgeladen und die
haben alle drei zusammen ich mich schon
eine millionen aufrufe und die gehen ja
mega ab und ihr freut euch immer wenn
etwas kommen weil eure kommentare da
vielleicht drin sind so weiter und so
fort
allerdings ist der nachteil bei diesen
böse kommentare lesen sachen dass ich
mich eigentlich nur bei die bösen
kommentaren lustig machen wollte
allerdings habe ich dadurch
hervorgerufen dass immer mehr böse
kommentare kommen das heißt ich gehe
teilweise und meine instagram bilder wo
ich mir zumindest bild post sohn
anstalten darunter die holen so
neuenachricht spaß neuenahr idiot
neuenachricht echte komme ich jetzt in
böse kommentare und ein extra mit
rechtschreibfehlern gezwungenermaßen
so kommt man nicht rein so wird man nur
blockiert
und zwar wäre ich ganz sehr
wahrscheinlich unbedingt in dumme
instagram kommentare wo ich einfach
hinter den letzten zehn bildern die ich
immer so gepostet ab so ein richtig
dummen kommentar auswählen wie
beispielsweise bei einem bild hab ich
geschrieben 5000 km h
windgeschwindigkeit runter mein vater
arbeitet bei blauem blut sind gar keine
5000 gamal ausgang gar nicht sein schon
längst weggeflogen solche kommentare
wollte ich dann vielleicht einfach so
ein videos dran nehmen und so eine dumme
instagram kommentare serie machen aber
mal schauen aber böse kommentare lesen
wird nicht mehr kommen schaust du
momentan eine serie schaut derzeit immer
noch frischen break seit einem halben
jahr oder so dann schaue ich leite wie
seit ein paar tagen finde ich aber nicht
so toll aber zwinge ich mich zu sehen
dass weiter zuschauen weil die ganze
theorie hinter der serie recht
interessant ist und sonst auf youtube
scheuch derzeit entlang die daily blogs
und von dan brown das ja auch schon seit
zwei jahren mache und hilfe der freunde
das was von diesem frage antwort video
ich habe versucht die frage ein bisschen
schneller zu beantworten so dass das
ganze video nicht so unendlich lange
wenn ihr wissen wollt was in letzter
zeit so bei mir los war und dies mit
dann könnt ihr mir bei twitter ins web
oder web chat folgen
der könnte jetzt nicht drauf klicken
oder so aber dass das könnt ihr ein
geben in eurem browser oder steht auch
in der beschreibung umsonst bedanke ich
mich fürs zuschauen und wir sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder tschüss